jimmy can you have somebody unmute your
line please
thank you okay
uh we will get started here
ellie and mctv go ahead
hey jimmy um tell me about you guys
were able to close up the lead towards
the end tell me about the no
quit attitude that this team has
we've never given up giving up but
i think it gets old playing from behind
consistently especially against a great
team like boston and what they bring to
the table
um so yeah we don't quit but we don't
ever want to
well i wouldn't say ever but we should
stop putting ourselves in a position and
start playing
our type of basketball from the jump
rachel nichols
sort of one idea of why you guys lost
this game what would you say
um we uh we didn't play hard enough
i think we didn't do anything that we
said that we were going to do
we knew how they were going to attack
because we weren't helping each other we
weren't making an
extra pass a lot of the times we weren't
playing basketball the way that we have
been to win the games that we have been
winning
we understand that so
you know there's nothing that coach can
say there's nothing that og can say
we get it you know we have to be the one
to fix that
cooper moorhead shouldn't be 60 points
in the paints
and the paint for them i know you guys
are going to look down and break down
the film but
where were the breakdowns offensively
that had them get into the room so often
we just got to stand in front of our man
simple as that i think we put too much
um
on bam to always be there and he can't
save us
uh every single time he's great at help
defense he's great on the ball
but um he already does enough for us you
can't just
get beat and expect for bam to come and
save you every time
david from la gazetta hello sport italy
hey jimmy you mentioned bam what did you
see from him tonight
he did everything he could to try to
willis
to this win all game long
passing the ball guarding obviously
scoring and rebounding the basketball
we continue we continually need him to
play like that which he will
and i will bounce back
let's say on my orga oh sorry hold on
mateo go ahead hi jimmy
how important has the council of team
captain udonis haslam been throughout
this playoff run and
what advice did he give the guys in the
locker room after the loss
sir uh that um this is part of
basketball
you know we want to win them all
sometimes you don't
but all in all we just had to play
harder play more together
and be more locked in i'm not going to
say that we thought that this was going
to be easy because it's not the case
but we got to put up a lot more fight
from the jump i mean
be the national team be the more
scrappier team
uh that's what he said at halftimes what
he said before the game and after the
game so
hopefully we understand that coming in
the next time we play
anthony chang hey jimmy 21 assists for
you guys i
seem a little noticed with the way you
guys play offensively did you like the
way
the looks you guys got and you know 12
44 on threes
uh i always like the looks that we have
um like i said earlier
i don't think we made the extra pass a
lot of the time
and that's not because anybody on our
team is selfish that's definitely not
the case
i just think um sometimes we take it
upon ourselves to try to get us back in
the games
you know i'm never complaining on about
anybody's shots
but on a defensive end i think that's
when we definitely didn't help each
other so
got to be better on that part and last
question tab the poor test from puerto
rico
hi jimmy how do you feel to be a leader
for this john team in a conference
finance
and the way the team is is playing right
now
i think we're playing well i think we
could play better um i love going to war
with these guys though
i say it time and time again um now we
really see what we're made of
you know they won a game you can say
that they have the momentum
now it's up to us to come in and win the
next one we're definitely capable of it
we got a lot of fix and we got to get
back to playing basketball the way that
we know how
jimmy thanks for your time sir have a
nice evening
all right everybody we will update
tomorrow